what did it was so simple but it was so
simple what did it was so that's hard to
say
I'm just saying hey Caesar I was gonna
do like the Hales but that clearly looks
like Hitler I can't do that so Hail
Caesar is another film written and
directed by the Coen brothers it
ultimately stars George Clooney and Josh
Brolin has a pretty solid all-star cast
sprinkled in there as secondary
characters and extras but I'm going to
narrow it down to those two otherwise
I'm gonna be here all day long Rayden
from Mortal Kombat the movies in here
and really this movie is a love letter
to old-school 1950s Hollywood and the
film production therein that happened
back then but the trailer narrows it
down and makes you think it's all about
George Clooney gets kidnapped then
there's a ransom demand that goes to
Josh Brolin cos Josh Brolin's the studio
guy that gets stuff done so now Josh
Brolin's kind of wrapped into this crime
comedy that takes place at old-school
Hollywood and granted that does happen
in this movie but first and foremost
this is a love letter to old-school
Hollywood by the Coen brothers and that
there were things that I really loved in
this movie and there were other things I
was like that's just messy as let's
just call it what it is this movie
started out I was actually on board with
it first of all I like the movie within
the movie things really cool seeing this
huge big-budget old biblical movie like
the Ten Commandments you know I mean it
really it is legit this looks like a
film of that time there were a couple of
bits of dialogue one of them is near the
beginning of the movie and I was like I
am loving this is one of the best peas I
this is good and another one
happens and I was like okay I'm in it
that if the movie keeps this up it can
be kind of quirky and really kind of
unrefined as long as you have sweet
dialogue in there that kind of stops and
then the cohesive direction of the film
as a whole stops but all in all this
movie being a love letter first it's
like the Coen brothers trapped us all in
their own little private joke that only
people in the Hollywood industry are
really gonna get that are super film
aficionados who aren't in Hollywood but
they're like I've read every Wikipedia
page on Hollywood I get it it's fine and
dandy but it doesn't make for a great
movie I mean if you're gonna make a love
letter look at quentin tarantino hateful
eight is a love letter to old school
seventy millimeter analog film but first
and foremost super cool movie this is
first and foremost a love letter and you
know I guess you just had to have people
doing things on screen to make it a
movie so that happened too if you shaved
off some of the side stories it would
have
you stuck the plot a bit more and made
it a bit more enjoyable as a movie and
although a number of side stories that
don't necessarily deal with the main
story can make the movie feel like it's
in a living breathing world it can also
bog down the movie and detract from the
overall experience and that's what
happened here and don't mean to
discredit the positives that are in this
movie this movie has a really neat
message about old Hollywood and how it
pertains to new Hollywood and really you
look at it you're like the problems now
existed then and 50 something years from
now people are going to look back and be
like Oh back in 2015 these problems
never existed then but they totally do
and rinse and repeat and that's how time
is going to go on guys in the end Hail
Caesar had the potential to be a really
cool crime to our comedy set in old
1950s Hollywood and although it does
seem that way in a couple of parts and
it had really cool dialog between
characters and a few scenes in the end
what you have is a Coen Brothers private
joke that some people are going to get
but other people are going to be left in
the cold you have a love letter that
sloppily pasted it's not really a
cohesive movie I'll say Hail Caesar is a
pretty good time if you're drunk yeah
now it's a but the did you give it
Coen Brothers movie Adele God you're
gonna get it now alright guys so Hail
Caesar have you seen it what did you
think about it where does it rank and
the Coen Brothers film hierarchy for you
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more